el lado de Canadá y grasa para eso
oportunidad de introducir leyes, pero
recibió hebe artista desconocido
ozeia enana aqui en Recife donde se hizo
un gran fan de radio canada y sin
la duda es el sido influenciado por el maestro
estimada prensa nacional canadiense
Estoy grabando aquí desde Fred Studio aquí.
en Toronto
Estoy encantado de decidir sobre nuestro
área seria se ha convertido en otra serie
introspectivo para estar adentro en la vida de
artistas aún no reconocidos
listo y no queremos todos
los artistas son famosos por derecho propio
directamente de los pintores rápidos y tendremos
un mundo único del aspirante a artista
gerencia cea rio para abreviar fue
comenzó en el año 2014 concluyó valkyrie
m pareja por los examenes vengo
consciente en 3 sobre el artista local
en comparación con los ya ricos artistas y
famoso
simplemente el público local quería
conocer a los artistas locales
creamos usado extra ir a través de él
el arte y nuestras propias habilidades
artes y ofrecer un servicio de
producción de video de alta calidad para
ayuda en los ejercicios diseña tu
historias y formas de arte como
weddell fuselos empresa de producción
banco múltiple ángulos múltiples
camara de edicion creativa y musica
original en todas nuestras producciones desde
nuestros inicios en 2014 y menos
estableció un segmento respetado en el
comunidad artística que kenny frunció el ceño
una madeja de historia inspiradora en el
creación de perfiles de artistas y también
coberturas
artistas interesados ​​en continuar con una
video promocional a contáctenos al
arowana sharon equipo elton john y yo
no es solo dios o buscar en internet
www top está en contacto y puede
llevar dos walter el corazón a través
de arte
la habitación de al lado